estos residentes de nikópol están
luchando para arreglárselas con lo que
queda de sus hogares después de haber
sido víctimas de tres rondas de
bombardeos rusos la noche anterior con
su ciudad a sólo 10 km de la central
nuclear de shapur y allá algunos
residentes temen que se produzca una
catástrofe mayor
todos moriremos si se produce una
catástrofe nuclear no sólo nosotros aquí
en ucrania sino todo el mundo esto es
muy grave
mi marido compró este apartamento porque
quería dejar algo a sus hijos
y murió y no dejo nada a sus hijos
la central nuclear de sabor y allá la
mayor de europa está ocupada por el
ejército ruso desde marzo cerca de la
línea del frente los alrededores de la
planta han sido blanco de bombardeos en
las últimas semanas moscú y kiev
intercambian culpas por los ataques
mientras crece la preocupación por un
inminente desastre nuclear el viernes el
presidente ruso vladimir putin aceptó
que los inspectores de la oiea el
organismo de vigilancia nuclear de las
naciones unidas visitaran la planta pero
aún no se ha fijado una fecha algunos
expertos afirman que sap orillas lo
suficientemente resistente como para
evitar que se repita el desastre nuclear
de chernobil de 1986
es muy robusta incluso contra la caída
de objetos y aviones tiene cáscaras de
hormigón reforzado de 20 metros de
grosor y que puede resistir el fuego de
la artillería pesada
thierry luego rusia ha convocado una
reunión del consejo de seguridad de la
onu para el martes sobre la situación en
la planta llenando los residentes de
nikko polo sobre esperanzas de un
retorno de cierta calma